L welcome back to gr tour this time you
are with the wild card again for single
cup how does it feel to play in such a
strong tournament yeah it's always nice
I mean I'm I'm always uh happy to to be
part of such a strong event uh
especially the classical format uh which
is my favorite it's just allows me to to
think which is what I
like uh but yeah it feels good to be
here even um if not as a
um main um the participant but uh but to
get the wild card especially here in St
Louis which is where I live for several
years now it's it's uh definitely quite
nice last year you made actually eight
draws in the tournament all the games
finished in the draw and it was
absolutely unique result I think for you
what do you think will happen this year
what are your expectations yeah I'm
hoping to have at least one decision so
uh but yeah let's see how it goes I mean
it's uh it's super strong obviously and
I consider my last year result to be
good so uh yeah well in terms of the
games uh I try to fight always um um
doesn't matter so much the the result
but uh I was happy that I was uh
fighting and playing long games uh um
yeah I hope this year it will it will be
kind of better who do you think will be
fighting for the top places in this
tournament who is in the good shape I
think you were also following this whole
this rapid and Blitz event I really hope
it's me I don't know that's a good hope
yes who who who will be your compet
competitors yeah hard to say I mean um
Fabiano obviously uh came on top after
the rabbit and Blitz I mean he was
playing uh really strong um the last few
months uh but then he had a kind of like
not such a strong finish at the is of
man of course you could think that he
was playing lots of games and and maybe
he was a bit tired but um he came back
so you never know we have players like
fujan and Neo who are always um supposed
to be on the top so uh yeah very hard I
don't like to predict such things I just
like to try to use my chances and and
and play my best for sure and actually
lately you showed really good
performance in World Cup maybe could
even showed better one but also second
tied for second place in US CH
Championship are you happy in general
with how your career is developing at
the moment yeah pretty happy I mean um
of course you always feel that you can
do things better and that uh and that
you miss chances and so on but um
generally speaking I'm quite happy that
I'm still able to play at this level uh
at my age I'm not that young anymore uh
but I feel I feel good and um happy that
I can still compete I feel as I said
quite U quite good I'm really hoping
that I can uh keep playing at this level
for for I mean for a long time that's um
in general my goal so uh let's see how
it goes yeah what about the preparation
for this event who is helping you these
days yeah well uh um I'm working with
Vladimir chelo for already long time uh
uh so he's helping me uh for this event
as well um we did quite well I think in
the last few tournaments I mean he was
helping me also in the in the world cup
and
and in the US Championship uh so yeah I
hope uh we can continue the and even
improve or
results uh you also live not far away
from St Louis chess club as you
mentioned before that you live in St
Louis do you think this closeness to the
chess club and also the fact that you
live in the capital of American chess
and now International even chess I makes
it I mean has some impact on your chess
life chess career do you meet with
people chess players here yeah well it's
definitely um uh nice to to be here in
St Louis in general because you have a
lot of U CH players U all kind of things
related to chess is a nice atmosphere
for for a chess player um so um the club
has been very helpful of course uh to
have the support of the club it's it's
been quite important in my career and uh
and that's probably one of the reasons
that I was able to keep myself playing
at a decent level in the last several
years uh but yeah as I said before it's
also nice in general to be here because
you uh meet friends all the time you get
together play uh not not only chess but
maybe some other sports do some other
things and uh and in terms of playing
here I think it has some pluses and
minuses obviously like when you go away
from home you're I don't know kind of
more focused less distractions when you
play in your home
town then it's of course uh you can have
your your friends and stuff U coming to
cheer you up or uh just to watch you
play or give uh give some uh some
confidence but at the same time it can
be uh an extra uh let's say weight on
your energy and and and and sometimes
not good but I have played well in St
Louis traditionally so um yeah I'm
hoping that uh I can keep doing I
remember your son was visiting the the
plane Hall last year actually how is he
doing and he played also in the
simultaneous exhibition so how is he
doing is he still playing chair not so
much he kind of uh chose a different
path for the moment but he likes Sports
very much he's playing tennis and but he
follows chess uh 100% I mean he knows
all what's going on uh he even uh tried
to tries to give me advice all the time
so
uh and of course as he's uh uh older as
he gets older he he understands uh uh
better and better what's happening and
and that's also nice that's great thank
you so much for for the interview and
all the best of luck for you in the
tournament thank
[Music]
you